so areas between curves are one instance
of what happens with multiple curse they
don't have to be between liking the very
first example I showed you this morning
but very frequently they are between the
area is going to be equal to the
integral from A to B of one function
take away the other right which is the
same as like why are we taking away it's
because you're taking the difference
between three areas right so I'm going
to write it like this okay where it's
really important that we name these
right they can't just be in any random
order that you'd like you can say where
F is the one on top that one you start
with is going to give you the bigger
area and g is the one that's beneath it
right G is the lower function okay now
don't write this because I'm consciously
not writing it I prefer your wrap this
but they still among you all notice that
remember what we said was if you
accidentally get them the wrong way
round if you accidentally get the long
way around the only difference will be
it'll be the same number but it'll be
negative do you remember that so some of
you will say hey I've got a function
that takes care of negatives why did I
just say this
okay why don't you say that and who
gives a rip Lou that which ones f or g
right like f can be the one atop really
one below you're just gonna get a
positive anyway now I'm feeling really
asking you not to write this why do you
think I'm suggesting against it
understanding I've trained you well if
you write this this is the appeals are
saying I don't know no it's like I can't
distinguish between these two functions
or i'm too lazy to distinguish between
these two functions it's actually very
important that you know which one is
which and I would just quickly i went to
the example but i will show you quickly
why okay what if the area i wanted you
to work out was ok let's just do
something now what would the area
between these two functions be what
would the area me they're getting two
pieces right you've got this guy over
here that's between the two curves and
then yeah it is like it's between the
parabola and the cube function and then
you've got this guy right this is also
between the two curves ok but you can
see for the red one very Christmasy
today for the red one ok the cubic
function will be on top that'll be F
that's the upper function whereas for
the green one the parabola will be the
one at all ok I actually understanding
which one is which well that's kind of
something we're looking for right that
you can tell the difference ok I do that
oh it's simple ok let's put some let's
put some imaginary numbers on this show
me so let's call that one why did I put
some in negative negative 2 negative 1
and out of there
okay um what would the area be okay um I
would say let's call this what is this G
okay so this is like maybe I don't know
ah ok five so much expense upside down
right I have no idea what this would be
um let's just call it X cubed plus X
minus that's got your- it's got a little
italy you found I'm not actually going
to solve this okay I just need some
equation I just need some iframe so for
the first one which ones I'm pop again
the red area which ones are done it's
the cubic right so I'm going to say that
area I'll said red area is going to be
the integral from negative to the
negative 1 there my boundaries all the
QB take away okay sorry I'll take away
that guy right seven take away x squared
with respect X that'll give me the radio
yeah yeah you see it's the top take away
the bottom right what's on top of them
no one there to do the green right
firstly the boundaries change the
battery there now from negative 1 to 3
and then I switch them around I say wait
but now the parabola is the one on phone
right actually journey brushes it and
the cubic is the one beneath
cool wait because it's negative so you
would get like a logically Gary Wie's
worries you could get divorce yeah okay
all right I see what you mean the answer
is yes if they're negative what if I
yeah yeah because because then you need
the negative number to be smaller than
I'm gonna be the ones in front because
what's right if I've got okay so here's
my answers here's a graph town yeah and
that's a terrible graph and so this is
the area mine I'm interested in right
okay watch what happened let's call this
one F and call this one g okay which is
the one on top
is there your top now where is that area
like how could I shake it would be this
guy right yeah that's the area on top
clearly that's a smaller area and when I
do this guy right when I do f of X do
you agree with that f of X is going to
be the blue dots and the black lines
right so this number is a bigger
negative than this one but you wanted to
be bigger don't you because like say I
actually evaluated say this is negative
one and say this one would be negative
or three or something like that but it
needs to be bigger sorry that you get an
F title or being positive you see that
always gonna be home yes it's right
because the integrals take care of the
negatives for you that's the engines
thought it was different